the world health organization says at
least one child has died in connection
with the mysterious outbreak of severe
hepatitis a serious liver infection
affecting children in the united states
and in europe at least 169 cases have
been reported in 12 countries 17
children worldwide needed liver
transplants in the united states alabama
has reported nine cases in children
under 10 years old two required
transplants two cases were reported in
north carolina all were reported in
otherwise healthy children the cdc
issued a nationwide alert warning
parents and doctors to be on the lookout
for symptoms associated with hepatitis
cbs news chief medical correspondent dr
john lepuk is here with us this morning
john good morning good to see you all
right so how concerning is this for
parents
well it's still relatively rare right
fewer than two hundred cases but i was
on the phone last night with dr rachelle
olenski who's the head of the cdc of
course and she said they really are
are looking to figure out you know is
this the tip of the iceberg or is this
something that's going to pass they put
out a call for cases they're saying to
people out there doctors clinicians all
around the world certainly in the united
states please be on the lookout for this
is it too early to say what's causing it
well they're associated with a virus
it's a very common virus called
adenovirus and in some kids a certain
subtype called 41 but adenovirus is very
common it causes respiratory symptoms gi
symptoms 41 the subtype usually causes
nausea vomiting diarrhea and some
respiratory symptoms but it does not is
not known to cause this type of
hepatitis in normal kids and
immunocompromised kids kids whose immune
systems are depressed yes there have
been some case reports of hepatitis but
it's very mysterious right now and when
you look at the facts of this none of
the children had covid and they weren't
vaccinated so there's no tie to vaccines
in this case not in the united states
but in europe 19 of the 169 cases were
co-infections of adenovirus with the
hepatitis but what does that mean we're
not sure because it's very common we're
we're still in a pandemic
that's what yeah yeah that's a question
every parent looking at you right right
yes okay so nausea vomiting diarrhea
which of course that covers a lot a lot
of a lot of very common things um
you can have respiratory symptoms one of
the big things is jaundice right so if
you turn yellow and sometimes it may be
tough to see that believe it or not
especially a person of color so if the
urine turns very dark like brown that's
from breakdown product of bile of the
red blood cells that that ends up in the
urine so that's a little clue there but
also follow your gut as a parent i
always say the kid's just not
looking the way they should
follow your gut feeling about it contact
your doctor because there's a very easy
way to see if you have this problem
which is to get a blood test you can see
that the liver enzymes are elevated so
it's not like these mysterious things
where you say well i don't even have a
test for it there's a good test for it
well so how is it spread though because
i think a lot of you know is it
is it you know adult to child like right
it's both respiratory so in the air we
know about that but also something
called fecal oral which means which is
that doesn't sound good right let's see
let's get let's really bring up a bad
fixture it's icky but let's really talk
and we talked beforehand yeah let's
explain this so when a kid poops right
and wipes themselves they don't always
do a perfect job they may get a little
bit of stool on their finger now now the
the virus is on their their hand they
touch somebody else they touch an adult
the adult then has it on their hand they
touch their mouth or their eye or their
nose touch a kid in school i touch
another kid in school so that's i know
it's kind of icky to talk about this but
that's the bottom line that's one of the
ways that it spreads and that's why hand
washing so what's the treatment john
supportive care there are some
experimental antiviral treatments out
there there's nothing fda approved yet
that says okay this is uh how you treat
it same thing with a with a vaccine
there's no fda approved vaccine for this
for kids but it's supportive care
meaning they come into the hospital uh
fortunately i mean yes there were 17
kids around the world who needed liver
transplants i spoke to somebody at the
university of alabama who was involved
with the nine kids there including the
two who had the transplants they're all
doing fine right now so they do
supportive care they give them
intravenous fluids and oxygen if they
need it and things like that but so far
these kids are getting better but
let's you know one of the worst things
you can do in medicine is to say oh it's
adenovirus done i know what it is no we
have to declare this we don't know
what's going on we're going to keep our
eyes and ears open and we're going to
just keep the hypotheses coming in well
we really appreciate all the information
obviously we had tons of questions about
it so i'm sure parents at home did too
doctor
there's one last theory which is i just
want to quickly say which is that during
the pandemic uh there hasn't been as
many infections of adenovirus because
kids are home where they're there
so one theory is that oh maybe now
they're suddenly be exposed to it they
didn't realize that early on that oh
this is something that's normal and they
overreact in their immune system that's
one really kind of interesting theory
we'll have to keep an eye on that dr
john and poop thank you so much
appreciate it